As history often teaches us, sometimes human
beings are the biggest monsters of all.
Of course, when you join the ranks of the
SCP Foundation, that starts to seem even less
likely.
And why wouldn’t it?
After all, just look at some of the creatures
they encounter and keep in containment.
A giant unkillable lizard, a being with toothy
protrusions growing out of its body, a whole
host of immortal eldritch beings that could
destroy reality, and one sadistic old man
who drags unsuspecting victims into his own
personal hellscape.
Monsters are a dime a dozen to the Foundation,
humanity could never be anywhere near as evil
or as cruel as the real monsters, even on
their worst day.
Or at least, you’d think.
Researcher Keltzen had held much of the same
mentality, that the SCP Foundation had the
job of defending humanity from the real monsters
of the world.
And it was because of that belief that he
had never previously questioned the Containment
Procedures in place for SCP-1000.
These beings were a species of nocturnal and
omnivorous apes, usually with bodies covered
in either grey, brown, black, red or white
fur.
Possessing the same level of intelligence
as the common chimp, the SCP-1000s had been
colloquially described as a species known
as ‘Bigfoot’, linking them to the urban
legend about an ape-like being of dubious
existence.
Keltzen had hardly been surprised that Bigfoot
itself was an anomalous SCP.
There were already a number of others that
the Foundation had encountered that seemed
to have influenced popular folklore from different
parts of the world.
In fact, it was that unique sub-category of
anomaly that Keltzen was conducting research
into when he came across the SCP-1000 files.
He was trying to determine, in various cases,
which came first: the anomaly, or the legend?
Did the existence of SCP-1000s inspire earlier
human civilisations to pass on stories of
the Sasquatch?
Or had those word of mouth tales been somehow
to the very origins of SCP-1000 themselves?
Studying the files, Keltzen knew there was
a memetic disease infecting hominids like
SCP-1000.
The infection meant that anyone who observed
one of the Bigfoot creatures had at minimum
a 2% chance of suffering instantaneous brain
death.
It would make discovering the link between
the Sasquatch legends and SCP-1000 difficult,
not being able to directly look at the apes.
But Keltzen hoped he wouldn’t need to actually
observe the creatures, only find evidence
that proved which predated which: SCP-1000
or the legend of Bigfoot.
The population of SCP-1000 was limited, although
their highest concentrations were known to
be found in the Pacific Northwest region of
North America, as well as in the Himalayan
Mountain range in Asia.
Being stationed at a Foundation facility in
the US, Researcher Keltzen opted to mount
an expedition to the former location.
A few odd occurrences had taken place leading
up to his departure: his car tires had been
slashed, and now needed repairing.
Newspaper clippings were also left on Keltzen’s
desk that told of various hikers’ deaths
taking place in the Pacific Northwest.
A more paranoid person might interpret these
as subtle, indirect threats; it certainly
seemed as if someone in the SCP Foundation
wasn’t keen on Keltzen departing for his
research trip.
Nevertheless, he changed tact and called in
sick to work, sneaking away to a small airstrip
and boarding a light cargo plane that smuggled
him towards the forests of North America.
Once he had arrived, night was already falling.
Keltzen was on his own, traversing the woods
as the sun rapidly receded out of view behind
the treeline, leaving the forest in darkness,
save for the beam from his flashlight.
The researcher was hardly an outdoorsy type
and far from an expert at exploring the wilderness,
but he pushed on into the heart of the woods,
to the areas where the most sightings of SCP-1000
had been reported.
It wasn’t long before the torchlight fell
over something imprinted in the woodland floor:
a large footprint, left by something bipedal
and rather similar to an ape.
Venturing further, the sound of twigs breaking
caused Keltzen to whirl around.
The noise had come from nearby, making it
louder than the low, background ambiance of
the forest at night.
He swung his flashlight in the direction he
thought it had come from, only seeing the
shadows of branches cast against the tree
trunks.
Then, another noise, leaves rustling as something
passed by, followed by more snapping of twigs,
then the shaking of the leaves again.
This thing, whatever it might’ve been, was
encircling him.
Frantically, Keltzen tried to spot it with
his light.
When, suddenly, the beam fell over something
tall, a hulking figure moving between the
trees.
Even from that split second sighting, it was
clearly an instance of SCP-1000.
The momentary glimpse had reminded the intrepid
researcher of an important detail: he couldn’t
look at them.
A 2% chance of instant brain death seemed
too low to worry about, but Keltzen’s research
had described the effects of the memetic disease
to be cumulative: the longer an SCP-1000 ape
was observed, the higher the chance of being
killed on the spot by the infection.
Snapping his eyes shut as tight as he could,
Keltzen was frozen to the spot, at the mercy
of the sounds surrounding him.
The SCP-1000 was drawing closer, enough for
the researcher to detect its footsteps.
His pulse quickened, along with his breathing
to match.
Although he was already aware that the apes
weren’t known for being aggressive, but
hearing its heavy breathing as it drew nearer
was enough to make him uncertain.
Keltzen wasn’t sure if the Bigfoot would
attack him, or pass him by, but by far the
last thing he had expected…
was to hear it start speaking.
“Hu… man,” came a deep, gravely voice.
It was the kind of sound an animal makes that
can almost be mistaken for speech.
Keltzen wasn’t fully convinced it had been
a word, rather just his ears playing tricks
on him in a moment of heightened fear.
“Human,” it repeated, much clearer.
There was no mistaking it a second time: the
SCP-1000 had spoken.
“Y-you can talk?”
Keltzen exclaimed in disbelief.
The Sasquatch didn’t answer directly, instead
the researcher detected the sound of receding
footsteps.
There was a pause, as the SCP-1000 ape turned
back to Keltzen.
“Follow, human,” it said.
“Open your eyes and follow me.”
“What about the disease?”
Keltzen shouted, keeping his eyelids still
screwed shut.
“You’ll be safe,” the ape replied, before
it resumed walking away.
Cautiously opening his eyes and lifting his
flashlight, Keltzen could see the hairy figure
making its way through the forest, its back
to him.
He could see it; the researcher could look
directly at it and yet nothing seemed to be
happening.
No adverse side effects, no instant brain
death.
The odds were low, Keltzen reminded himself,
as he began to warily follow the path of the
ape.
Following at a distance, he made sure to momentarily
glance away, trying not to stare for too long
at the SCP-1000 creature, in the hope that
might disrupt the memetic effects of the infection.
Before long they had arrived at a cave, deep
in the heart of the forest.
The embers of a small fire were still aglow
near the rocky entrance.
As they lumbered inside, the SCP-1000 threw
extra wood on the fire, poking it with a long
stick until the flames began to reach higher.
The flickering orange gave Keltzen a better
look at the ape, its large frame, covered
almost head to toe in brown fur.
There was something about the creature that
seemed off, not unsettling but almost sad,
melancholic…
like it was lonely.
The researcher had been so amazed that he
could observe the creature for so long without
dying that he’d barely focused in on the
more important discovery: SCP-1000s were far
more intelligent than the Foundation files
had indicated, capable of not only speech,
but emotion too.
“D-do you have a name?”
Keltzen stammered, unsure where to start.
“Grykor,” it replied.
“That is my name.”
“You’ll have to forgive me, I’m a little
taken aback by all this,” the researcher
hastily explained.
“You’re able to articulate, your species
is advanced enough to have names.”
“Why should that be surprising?”
Grykor asked.
“Well, it’s just, the Foundation seems
to think you and your kind are…
I don’t mean any offense but, mindless beasts.”
The ape made a huffing, exhaling sound; Keltzen
noticed after a moment that they were chuckling,
a dry, almost sarcastic chuckle.
It was unlike anything he had expected to
learn about SCP-1000.
That reminded him of why he’d come here.
“Grykor, may I ask something?” he cleared
his throat.
Nodding, the SCP-1000 instance poked at the
fire again, paying little mind to the human
in its company.
“Where did you and your people come from?”
Keltzen asked.
“What’s your history?”
“Why?”
Grykor replied abruptly.
“You see, humans have these legends… stories
about something called Bigfoot, or a Sasquatch.
The Foundation, the humans I work with, they
call you one and the same.
I wanted to know if that was true.”
For a short moment, the creature paused.
Then, Grykor began to give Keltsen the truth;
the real truth.
And as they spoke, it was as if the researcher
could see the story unfolding, emphasized
by the pain in the ape’s teary eyes.
“We were like you, long, long ago,” it
began explaining.
“We and humans, we evolved together, side
by side.
For a time, there was peace between us.
But we began to grow faster, stronger, became
smarter while you were left behind.”
“You evolved before early humans did?”
Keltzen probed.
“Indeed,” Grykor answered with a gentle
nod.
“We began to surpass the humans.
You were still young, still hunting and foraging
for food while we were moving far beyond.
Thousands and thousands of years, we were
able to develop our culture, our technology,
all before the humans had even come close
to fire and the wheel.”
“But that doesn’t make any sense!”
the researcher interjected yet again.
“If that was the case, mankind would never
have had its chance to reach the top of the
food chain.
We would have died out, and that would have
made you the dominant species on the planet.”
“We were,” the SCP-1000 ape replied.
“For a time.”
“What happened?”
Grykor turned with a solemn look on their
face.
“You,” it replied plainly.
“Humans happened.
We covered the world, billions and billions
of us.
You were rare, as few as we are now.
My people made technology far beyond anything
humans have dreamt up; either before or since.
Trains, ships, vehicles created from the trees
and the animals.
Communication using parts of insects and smaller
creatures.
Cities filled with us, where we all lived
in harmony, stretched out across parts of
the world humans dared not to tread.”
“Organic technology,” Keltzen gasped.
“Fascinating!”
“We had weapons too.
And that was our biggest mistake.”
“What kind of weapons?”
the researcher quizzed the ape.
“Given how advanced you were compared to
humanity at that time, I’m assuming your
weaponry was far beyond our early spears and
clubs.”
“The devastating kind,” Grykor said, staring
ahead into the fire, almost as if the dancing
flames conjured up images of the kind of destruction
his ancestor’s weapons could cause.
“I think I understand,” Keltzen said.
“There was some kind of conflict, yes?
A majority of your people perished… oh,
my condolences.
But that would have removed you from the top
of the evolutionary chain, and allowed the
earliest ancestors of humanity to usurp your
place there?
Was the disease you and your species carry
a result of that war, a sort of lingering
radioactive fallout but on a genetic level?”
“We are not sick,” Grykor growled.
“Your people lied.
They made that up.
And there was no war…
it was a slaughter.”
Keltzen fell quiet, unsure of what to say.
“Humans would stay away from us back then.
We avoided them too.
You slept during the night when we were awake.
But you made a deal.
A deal with something ancient and dangerous
in the forests.
A deal to even the score.
You found our weapons… and didn’t hesitate.”
“No, that’s…” the Foundation researcher
tried to protest, but the look of sadness
on the ape’s face stopped his sentence before
he could finish.
“We were almost entirely wiped out, in a
single day.
Humans switched places with us, we became
less and they became more.
They used our technology to forget about us,
wiped their memories so they wouldn’t have
to face up to what they had done.
But we never forgot.”
“And the Foundation, they maintain that
façade,” Keltzen realised.
“That’s why they tell us you’re infected,
that if we look at you’ll we’ll die.
They’re ashamed, we…
we all should be.”
“Not just ashamed,” Grykor replied.
“Afraid.
They fear we want revenge, retribution for
what was done to our people.”
“And do you?”
The ape took another pause, as if it was pondering…
or just allowing itself a moment to feel sad.
“We have forgiven you,” it answered.
“I’m not sure we deserve that,” Kletzen
said back, as the pair sat by the fire until
the sun came up.
Now go and check out “SCP-323 WENDIGO SKULL”
and “SCP-023 BLACK SHUCK” for more anomalous
entities that are pulled straight out of folklore,
myths and ancient legends!